This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We have something a little different on the show this week. If it isn't obvious, I'm what you'd call pro infrastructure. Of course, some infrastructure is vital and necessary and some infrastructure isn't, but it all has to be made right. It's hard work, it's dangerous work, and it's often union work. This story is about New York City Sandhog's local 147, and they are the urban miners who build every tunnel in New York City and many of the bridge foundations.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。这周的节目内容有点不一样。显而易见，我是个坚定的基础设施支持者。当然，有些基础设施至关重要且不可或缺，有些则不然，但它们都必须建造得当。这是一项艰苦的工作，充满危险，而且通常是工会工作。这个故事讲的是纽约市沙工（Sandhogs）147地方工会，他们是城市矿工，建造了纽约市的每一条隧道以及许多桥梁地基。
Without them, there would be no sewers, no subways, no tunnels for cars, no water, basically no New York City. To quote the local 147 website, without the tunnels built by the Sandhogs, New York would have ceased to exist around the time of the American Civil War. local 147 website without the tunnels built by the Sandhawks, New York would have ceased to exist around the time of the American Civil War. So in 1994, radio producer Dan Klauson interviewed the Sandhawks as they were working on New York City Water Tunnel No. 3, and if you've seen the third diehard movie, Diehard with Evidence, you've seen New York City Water Tunnel No. 3 under construction.
没有他们，就不会有下水道、地铁、汽车隧道、水，基本上也就没有纽约市。引用147地方工会网站的话说，如果没有沙工建造的隧道，纽约在大约美国内战时期就会不复存在了。147地方工会网站说，如果没有沙工建造的隧道，纽约在大约美国内战时期就会不复存在了。所以在1994年，广播制作人丹·科利森（Dan Collison）采访了正在建造纽约市3号供水隧道的沙工们，如果你看过第三部《虎胆龙威》电影《虎胆龙威3》，你就见过正在建设中的纽约市3号供水隧道。
It's pretty amazing to see, and the voices of the Sandhawks responsible for building that tunnel are amazing to hear. Seriously, I can listen to them talk all day, but on this episode we'll just listen for 22 minutes. This is Sandhawks by Long Hall Productions produced in 1994 by Dan Colossan. Through the heart of a great metropolis, close the mighty Hudson River, a natural barrier between two states, a challenge to man's ingenuity, skill, and courage. Sixty years ago, the challenge was to build another tunnel under the Hudson River. The Holland tunnel and the George Washington bridge could no longer handle the mounting traffic between New Jersey and Manhattan. And so the Lincoln tunnel is started.
这景象相当震撼，而听到负责建造该隧道的沙工们的声音更是令人惊叹。说真的，我可以听他们聊一整天，但在本期节目中，我们只听22分钟。这是由长厅制作公司（Long Hall Productions）制作、丹·科利森于1994年制作的《沙工》。穿过大都市的中心，靠近雄伟的哈德逊河，这是两州之间的天然屏障，是对人类智慧、技能和勇气的挑战。六十年前，挑战是在哈德逊河下建造另一条隧道。荷兰隧道（Holland Tunnel）和乔治·华盛顿大桥（George Washington Bridge）已无法应付新泽西与曼哈顿之间日益增长的交通。于是，林肯隧道（Lincoln Tunnel）开工了。
It was 1934, the Great Depression, and jobs were scarce. In my day, when you were hungry, it would be anything. And to be a sandhog in Jim Murth's day, you had to work almost exclusively in compressed air. Air that was pumped into small, cramped underground chambers or casons to hold back the water and silt during tunneling. Under pressure work is a strain on hot and lungs. There is danger also of contracting an illness called the Benz. My early life I had trouble with the burns in my news. You had a way of curing it at home. you get into a hot cup of water and it would disappear and then you'd fall asleep, the water would get cold, it'd come right back and hit you,
那是1934年，大萧条时期，工作机会极为稀少。在我的年代，当你饿的时候，什么都行。要在吉姆·默斯（Jim Murth）的时代成为一名沙工，你几乎必须完全在压缩空气环境中工作。这种空气被泵入地下狭小逼仄的舱室或沉箱中，以便在掘进过程中阻挡水和泥沙。高压下的工作对心脏和肺部都是一种负担。还得面对患上潜水病（the Bends）的危险。我早年的时候，鼻子里的烧灼感让我很头疼。你们有一种在家治疗的方法，泡进一杯热水里它就会消失，然后你就会睡着，水变凉了，它又会卷土重来击中你，
like a toothache, a very, very bad toothache. It's the same problem deep seed divers have when they come up to the surface too fast. Severe cramps, and in some cases paralysis, they can even lead to death. Around the turn of the century during construction of the Pennsylvania railroad tunnels, the bends took the lives of at least 50 sandhogs. Initially, the men were declared dead of natural causes. Later, it was revealed that the death certificates had been falsified to cover up unsafe working conditions. Public hearings led to public outrage, and eventually a sandhog's union was born. We didn't have the union would have nothing. Believe me when I tell you absolutely nothing. You think there would be any kind of wages or any kind of conditions that the contractor was gonna give you? A rich man got rich because he
就像牙痛，非常非常严重的牙痛。这和深海潜水员过快浮出水面时遇到的问题是一样的。剧烈的痉挛，在某些情况下还会瘫痪，甚至导致死亡。在世纪之交宾夕法尼亚铁路隧道施工期间，潜水病夺去了至少50名沙工的生命。最初，这些人被宣布为自然死亡。后来，人们发现死亡证明被伪造了，以掩盖不安全的工作条件。公开听证会引发了公众的愤怒，最终沙工工会诞生了。如果我们没有工会，就会一无所有。相信我，绝对一无所有。你以为承包商会给你发什么工资或者提供什么条件吗？富人之所以富有，是因为他
was holding on. It was money. He isn't gonna give it away to a bunch of slabs. So the union came in. I'm going to read the title of the local, but you must remember that we came from an international union of compressed air workers. That's why the title is compressed air and free air tunnels, foundations, casings, subways, sewer, confidam, construction workers union of New York, New Jersey, states, and vicinity. That's the title. Edward McGuinness is a former president of the Sandhogs Union, local 147 for short.
把钱抓在手里。那是钱，他才不会把它施舍给一帮粗人。所以工会进驻了。我要宣读这个地方工会的名称，但你们必须记住，我们来自一个压缩空气工人的国际工会。这就是为什么它的全称是纽约州、新泽西州及周边各州的压缩空气和自由空气隧道、地基、沉箱、地铁、下水道、围堰建筑工人联合会。这就是它的全称。爱德华·麦吉尼斯（Edward McGuinness）是沙工工会（简称147地方工会）的前主席。
McGuinness's father was a sandhog, a foreman, and as a kid growing up across the street from the bar where his father recruited his work crew, young Eddie decided he wanted nothing to do with the business. The banging on the bar and the fights that went on there, I was petrified. I never thought I would go near anybody that was a sandhog, never mind working for them. But despite his vow to stay away, Eddie McGinnis, like a lot of sandhogs, ended up following
麦吉尼斯的父亲是一名沙工、工头，作为一个在酒吧街对面长大的孩子，他父亲就在那里招募施工队，年轻的埃迪决定与这行划清界限。酒吧里的砸桌声和那里发生的打斗，把我吓坏了。我从来没想过要接近任何当沙工的人，更不用说为他们工作了。但尽管发誓要远离，埃迪·麦吉尼斯像许多沙工一样，最终还是跟随
his father down into the tunnels. Economics decides a lot of our lives. And it decided mine. I know the first time I went into a tunnel and they set off a blast of about 200 sticks of powder. I said, what, and the name of God brought me to this place. That was my reaction. I'm going home and never coming back.
父亲走进了隧道。经济状况决定了我们大部分的人生，也决定了我的人生。我知道我第一次进隧道时，他们引爆了大约200支炸药。我说，天哪，是什么把我带到了这个地方。这就是我的反应，我要回家，再也不回来了。
But when I went home, I had young children, and I had to come back. And John's everything else is good? Yeah. How you feeling, Patty? John's everything else is good? Yeah. How you feeling, Patty? Good. You doing all right? Yeah.
但当我回到家时，我有年幼的孩子，我必须回来。约翰，其他一切都好吗？是的。感觉怎么样，帕特？约翰，其他一切都好吗？是的。感觉怎么样，帕特？很好。你一切都好吗？是的。
Good man, Pat. 10 years ago, there were 2,300 members of local 147, headquartered here in a small office in the Bronx. Today, there are only about 700 members, and almost half of those are pensioners. All are men. Richard Fitzsimons is the business manager for local 147. We had women, they did go down, there was I think three women, and they worked alongside,
好样的，帕特。10年前，147地方工会有2300名会员，总部设在这里布朗克斯的一个小办公室里。如今，会员只剩下大约700人，其中近一半是退休人员。全都是男性。理查德·菲茨西蒙斯（Richard Fitzsimons）是147地方工会的业务经理。我们曾有过女工，她们确实下过井，我想大概有三名女性，她们和大家并肩工作，
they've done the best they could, but they didn't come back after lunch, it was just the work too tough. I'm a firm believer that a woman should do whatever she can in life to support herself, but I don't think that San Hg is a place for a woman. I might put it this way, I wouldn't want to see my wife with my daughter, San Hogg. His son is another matter. Richie Fitzsimont started working as a sand hog six days after he graduated from high school.
她们尽了最大努力，但午饭后她们就没再下来，因为工作实在太辛苦了。我坚信女性应该在生活中尽其所能养活自己，但我认为沙工不适合女性。换句话说，我可不想看到我的妻子或女儿当沙工。他的儿子则是另一回事。里奇·菲茨西蒙斯（Richie Fitzsimons）高中毕业六天后就开始当沙工了。
Today, he's the president of local 147. It's basically a father's son union. Just about everybody has either had their father, or their brother is a sandhog, or their cousin, and it's a small, but a tight knit union, and the union is in such a way that it's almost like an extended family. And local 147 is a union that has long prided itself
如今，他是147地方工会的主席。这基本上是一个父子工会。几乎每个人的父亲、兄弟或表亲都是沙工，这是一个规模虽小但凝聚力极强的工会，工会的运作方式就像一个大家庭。147地方工会一直以其
on its racial and ethnic diversity. Yeah, Tom McHugh's my name. I'm a son talk. has long prided itself on its racial and ethnic diversity. I was born, born, raised in Brooklyn, and I live down in Jersey shore right now. And when I was in Sanhawk 30 years, I was born in by a fellow named Charlie Dirty, Donnie Goalboy, and a lot of Donnie Goalboys in his local. Same as we do have West Indy and Jamaicans, Polish. We have a good contingency Polish fellows from Queens. My name is Lin Kone Ritchets. I am from St. Vincent West Indies, and I've been a sunhawk for 23 years. Lincoln Richards speaks almost reverentially
种族和族裔的多样性而自豪。是的，我叫汤姆·麦克休（Tom McHugh）。我是一名沙工。一直以其种族和族裔的多样性而自豪。我在布鲁克林出生长大，现在住在泽西海岸。当我当了30年沙工时，我……由一个叫查理·多蒂（Charlie Doty）的人带进门，他是个多尼戈尔（Donegal）人，这个工会里有很多多尼戈尔人。就像我们也有西印度群岛人、牙买加人、波兰人一样。我们有一大批来自皇后区的波兰小伙子。我叫林肯·理查兹（Lincoln Ricketts）。我来自圣文森特西印度群岛，我已经当了23年沙工。林肯·理查兹用近乎虔诚的语气
about the unity of local 147 that no matter how they might feel about each other above ground, down below, sandhawgs are like family. Very close. You can just finish fighting with a man in the change house. You get on the elevator and you go down to work and it's your brother. It shares last meal with you. It shares anything with you. It look out for you. You know, anything he do for you. That's how beautiful a relationship we have.
谈到147地方工会的团结，无论他们在地面上对彼此有什么看法，在地下，沙工们就像一家人一样。非常亲密。你可能刚在更衣室和一个人打完架，然后你坐上电梯下去工作，他就是你的兄弟。他会把最后一顿饭分给你，会把任何东西分给你，会照顾你。你知道的，他会为你做任何事。我们的关系就是这么美好。
We had integration, so to speak, before any of this ever came out about integration, but what we even knew about integration Huey Bar worked as a sandhog for 35 years before retiring in 1987 You know, you could work with Pollock's I was Irish Irish American I'd work in Pollock gangs and what have you you know black gangs also That was the method of operation. It was our work rules. It was our work rules It's always been that way since San Haga. In New York, one of the most important work rules, if not the most important, is that you have to have a union card to work as a sandhawk. But being in the union doesn't guarantee a job.
可以说，在任何关于融合的消息传出之前，在我们甚至知道融合是什么之前，我们就已经实现了融合。休伊·巴尔（Huey Barr）当了35年沙工，于1987年退休。你知道的，你可以和波兰人一起工作——我是爱尔兰裔、爱尔兰裔美国人——我会和波兰人班组一起工作，诸如此类，还有黑人班组。这就是运作方式。这是我们的工作规则。这也是我们的工作规则。自沙工诞生以来一直如此。在纽约，最重要（如果不是最重要的话）的工作规则之一就是，你必须拥有工会会员证才能当沙工。但加入工会并不能保证有工作。
Tunnel work is scarce these days. Several hundred members of local 147 are out of work. Most of those who do have jobs are working on City Tunnel No. 3, a massive construction project that when finished will give much of New York City a brand new water system. City Tunnel No. 3 is badly needed. New York's existing water system, some of which dates back to the turn of the century, is so antiquated, City officials are reluctant to turn off the valves to inspect the tunnels because they're afraid the valves are so corroded they won't be able to turn them back on again. A small part of city tunnel number three is shaft 21b beneath the heart of Brooklyn.
如今隧道工作很稀缺。147地方工会的几百名会员失业在家。大多数有工作的人都在3号市水隧道（City Tunnel No. 3）工作，这是一个庞大的建设项目，完工后将为纽约市大部分地区提供全新的供水系统。3号市水隧道极其迫切需要。纽约现有的供水系统，其中一部分可以追溯到世纪之交，已经如此陈旧，以至于市政府官员都不敢关闭阀门来检查隧道，因为他们担心阀门已经严重腐蚀，无法再次打开。3号市水隧道的一小部分是位于布鲁克林市中心下方的21B竖井。
You ready for the drill bucket? Yes, that's it. Okay. It's early on a Monday morning and a crew of sandhogs is about to go to work inside Chaff 21b, 500 feet below street level. Oh, we're getting ready to go down the drull now. I'm going to be drulling for maybe three or four hours. And then we get the dynamite down there, it will be blasting.
准备好钻斗了吗？是的，就是这样。好的。那是星期一清晨，一队沙工正准备前往位于街面下500英尺的21B竖井内部工作。哦，我们现在准备下竖井了。我要钻孔大概三四个小时。然后我们把炸药运下去，就要进行爆破了。
We use about 300 pounds of dynam of the anyways. For a blast. Good job, good job. The crew is off to a slow start this morning. There is an electrical problem, so it's pitch black at the bottom of the shaft. No lights, Dennis. Can't check the paddle. The problem is quickly fixed, and the first group of sandhugs dressed in hard hats and bright yellow rain slickers steps inside a metal cage and descends. Give me one kiss and I'll be happy.
我们每次爆破要用大约300磅炸药。干得好，干得好。今天早上这支队伍开局有些慢。电路出了问题，所以竖井底部一片漆黑。没有灯，丹尼斯。无法检查滑轮。问题很快得到了解决，第一批戴着安全帽、穿着亮黄色雨衣的沙工走进金属笼，开始下降。给我一个吻，我就会很高兴。
All right, load it up. load it up. I'm back door's closed. Yes, it is. All right. All right. Go down. The next sound you're about to hear is
好了，装满。装满。后门关上了吗？是的，关上了。好的。好的。下去吧。接下来你将听到的声音是
men in cage going down. Men in motion. For most sandhawks, the first trip into a shaft or tunnel was the moment of truth, the point at which they knew whether or not they had what it takes to be in the business. You can tell the minute you step on a cage and you start going down, whether you do or you don't have it in it. Mike Jimenez grew up not too far from this site. For as long as he can remember Jimenez says he wanted to be a sandhog. People are mesmerized by the saying what did you do and
工人们乘笼子下降。行动中的人们。对大多数沙工来说，第一次下竖井或隧道是真理的时刻，是他们知道自己是否具备吃这行饭的潜质的时刻。你踏上笼子开始往下掉的那一分钟，就能看出你到底有没有这块料。迈克·希门尼斯（Mike Jimenez）在这个工地附近长大。吉梅内斯说，只要他记事起，他就想成为一名沙工。人们被这种说法迷住了，问你做过什么，
we tell him we boldly go with no man has ever gone before. We've come across Virgin Rock. This rock has been here since the beginning of time. Nobody's ever done this before. Not every sandhog shares this romantic view of the work. Charlie Cannon is a second-generation sandhog. It's more economic than there's anything else. We don't come here for the glory of being the first one to be where nobody else has walked. It's basic economic. You've got to feed your family, pay your bills, and try to get ahead in this life. That's the whole picture. Whether they work for the glory or the paycheck,
我们告诉他们，我们勇敢地去往从未有人涉足的地方。我们遇到了处女岩。这块岩石自盘古开辟以来就一直在这里。从来没有人做过这种事。并非每个沙工都对这项工作抱有这种浪漫的看法。查理·卡农（Charlie Cannon）是第二代沙工。这比什么都更出于经济考量。我们来这里不是为了成为第一个走到无人涉足之地的荣耀。这是最基本的经济需求。你得养家糊口，支付账单，努力在这生活中出人头地。这就是全貌。无论他们是为了荣耀还是为了薪水而工作，
sandhogs work together in extremely close quarters. Here at the bottom of Shaft 21B, 10 sandhogs and a battery of heavy equipment are packed into a space about the size of a large hot tub. The walls are jagged rock, granite, quartz, limestone, illuminated by a panel of floodlights. As you can tell it's cramped. Sa'dine. So this is what it's like to be a life of a Sa'dine? Yes. Close to it. Yeah baby, you don't get any better than this stuff. It's like working at the bottom of an empty missile side in a rain forest.
沙工们在极其狭窄的空间里协同工作。在这里，21B竖井的底部，10名沙工和一堆重型设备挤在一个差不多大型按摩浴缸大小的空间里。四周是参差不齐的岩石、花岗岩、石英、石灰岩，被一排泛光灯照亮。正如你所看到的，这里非常逼仄。沙丁鱼。所以这就是沙丁鱼般的生活吗？是的。差不多吧。是的，宝贝，没有比这更好的了。这就像在一个雨林中的空导弹发射井底部工作。
Groundwater pours down from the rock walls above, collecting in need-deep pools below where the sandhogs are getting ready to drill. They pull out big, pneumatic jackhammers, attach long drill bits, and start boring holes for the dynamite. The opening at the top of the shaft, 65 stories up, looks like a pinhole. If something were to fall from above, even a small rock or a hard hat, it could be deadly.
地下水从头顶的岩石壁倾泻而下，汇聚在沙工们准备钻孔的膝盖深的积水潭中。他们拉出大型气动风镐，装上长钻头，开始为炸药钻孔。竖井顶部的开口，即65层楼高的地方，看起来像个针孔。如果有什么东西从上面掉下来，哪怕是一块小石头或一顶安全帽，都可能是致命的。
It's like being in a funnel. There's no escape. There's no escape from anything that falls. It was into a shaft similar to this one, shaft 19 in Queens, that something did fall, something big. Last November, the day before Thanksgiving, a 16-ton winch broke loose from its mooring at the top of the shaft. Tom Flanagan and Mike Boyce were two of eight sandhawks who were working 450 feet below on a catwalk
这就像在一个漏斗里。无处可逃。对任何落下的东西都无处可逃。正是在一个类似于这个竖井的地方——皇后区的19号竖井，确实有东西掉下来了，而且是个大东西。去年11月，感恩节前一天，一个16吨重的绞车从竖井顶部的固定点脱落。汤姆·弗拉纳根（Tom Flanagan）和迈克·博伊斯（Mike Boyce）是八名在450英尺深处的猫道上工作的沙工中的两人，
about 50 feet from the bottom when the huge winch plummeted downward. We know all of a sudden notice that cable got slack real fast and we looked up and all we see was this big snake coming out. It's the cable that's coming. And we couldn't see the surface due to the fog. So the cable was beating us up real bad, knocking everybody all about. And that big, big winch come through
距离底部约50英尺，这时巨大的绞车轰然坠落。我们突然发现电缆极快地松弛下来，我们抬头看，只见这条大蛇冲了出来。那是飞驰而来的电缆。由于雾气，我们看不到地面。所以电缆把我们抽打得非常惨，把所有人都撞得东倒西歪。然后那个巨大无比的绞车冲了下来，
and all hell broke loose. Everything was flying all over and had no warning at all. He had a...I seen flashes out of the corner, am I right? I sounded like an explosion. Did that broke loose? And I was at my foot caught in a cable, my fingers and a grate hanging upside down. I was going to drop in a water or pick a brick while fall because I was slipping and like it's all the other guys I thought of my two kids and turn my hand around and the grate and stuck it in again and just let my foot loosen the
顿时乱作一团。所有东西都在飞舞，完全没有任何预警。他有一个……我眼角余光看到了闪光，对吗？听起来像是一次爆炸。那个脱落了？我的脚缠在电缆里，手指和格栅挂着，头朝下。我本要掉进水里或者坠落砸死，因为我在打滑，就像其他所有人一样，我想到了我的两个孩子，把手转过来抓住格栅，再次插进去，然后把脚从电缆里抽出来，
cable and itch my way up to a good cable and pull myself up on the deform. I managed to get up to a flat piece of deck and just hang on, it'll piece a post on a guardrail and just hope them prayed until the dust settled until everything stopped coming. We were all very lucky that made it out of there. I just wish Anthony could have been as lucky as the rest of us. Anthony Odo was the 20th sandhog to be killed during construction of the water tunnel. That averages out to almost one fatality a year.
一路挪到一根好的电缆上，把自己拉到平台上。我设法爬到一块平坦的甲板上，紧紧抓住，抓住护栏上的一个柱子，只能祈祷灰尘落定、所有东西停止下落。我们能活着逃出来真是太幸运了。我只是希望安东尼能像我们其他人一样幸运。安东尼·奥多（Anthony Odo）是在水隧道建设期间丧生的第20名沙工。平均下来几乎是一年一人。
You come here today to pray for the heroic men and women who made such tremendous sacrifices that the people of the city of New York would have water, life-giving water, for all the days of their lives and for generations yet to come. At St. Barnabas Church in the North Bronx, on senior coincidine holds a special mass each year in memory of the Sandhogs killed working on the water project. And so now we'll list the names of those if you stand as a tribute to men who have suffered a sacrifice for the work of our tunnel. Charles Specky Amina, Joseph Barton, the operating engineer, Stuart Birdzall. The first guy got killed on the water tunnel construction.
你们今天来这里，是为了祈祷那些做出巨大牺牲的英雄般的男女们，好让纽约市的人民拥有水，拥有生命之水，世世代代永享甘露。在北布朗克斯的圣巴拿巴教堂（St. Barnabas Church），高级神父科因蒂恩（ConCidine）每年都会举行一次特别弥撒，以纪念在水利工程施工中牺牲的沙工。现在我们将宣读这些人的名字，请大家起立，向为我们隧道工程作出牺牲的人们致敬。查尔斯·斯佩基·阿米娜（Charles Specky Amina）、约瑟夫·巴顿（Joseph Barton，操作工程师）、斯图尔特·伯德佐尔（Stuart Birdzall）。第一个在水隧道施工中丧生的人。
Got killed about 20 feet away from me on a walk there. To hear that man moan with the pain. It was something, I mean, you know, I'll never forget that as long as I live you'll be Jay Horton minor Thanks sir one accident. I'll never forget brother in battery tunnel happened on Easter Saturday They put a guy on a motor That tunnel really had a bad slope and the great wonder about four degrees They were shutting the inside the lock
在猫道上距离我大约20英尺的地方被砸死。听到那个男人的痛苦呻吟。那真是一场……我的意思是，你知道的，我这辈子都不会忘记那件事。你将成为杰·霍尔顿（Jay Horton），矿工。谢谢先生。一次事故。我永远不会忘记，在复活节星期六，电池隧道发生的事情。他们把一个人放在一辆机车上。那条隧道坡度真的很陡，大约有四度。他们在锁孔里面关门。
He came down with the motor he couldn't stop at the breakman jump, broke his leg, he hit the door, the battery jumped up, caught him in half. They come in and they got Andy and Andy took me with him and went over and put him in a sack and brought him out. I vomited the whole night. Yeah And that's what I would like to do. That's it. Lord have mercy. Christ have mercy. Lord have mercy. For every sandhawk who is killed on the job, there are hundreds, maybe thousands, of close calls.
他连着机车冲了下来，刹车失灵，刹车手跳车摔断了腿，他撞上了门，机车弹起来，将他拦腰截断。他们进来后找到了安迪，安迪带上我和他一起过去，把他装进麻袋带了出去。我吐了一整夜。是的。这就是我想做的。就这样。主啊，怜悯我们。基督，怜悯我们。主啊，怜悯我们。每一个在工作中丧生的沙工背后，都有成百上千次、甚至上万次死里逃生的经历。
The most legendary took place in 1916. As the story goes, Marshall maybe was working in compressed air in a tunnel below the East River. There was a blowout. Maybe in two other sand dogs were shot out through a hole and up through the riverbed on a geyser, 25 feet high. They were mining and they didn't have the equipment in there and up to stop that blow.
最传奇的一次发生在1916年。故事是这样的，马歇尔·梅比（Marshall Maybie）当时正在东河下方的一条隧道里进行压缩空气作业。发生了一次井喷。梅比和其他两名沙工被一股25英尺高的间歇泉从洞口冲出，直冲上河床。他们当时正在掘进，那里没有设备来阻止那场井喷。
And he tried to stop it and he went up through the river with two other guys. And he survived. The other two went died. The story seemed to catch attention because Marshall maybe went back. He was in a long-time college hospital. I think he only spent a couple of days in the hospital. And he was back working as quick as he could.
他试图阻止它，结果和另外两个人一起被冲上了河面。他活了下来，另外两人死了。这个故事似乎引起了人们的关注，因为马歇尔·梅比又回去了。他在一家长效医院呆过。我想他只在医院呆了几天，就尽快回去工作了。
I tell you, you talk to most sandbags and they're going to tell you, one of your times up, your times up. Whether you're walking down the street or working underground, just going to go. You're going to go. When the man says it's time, you're gone. That's all. Simple as that. Just wasn't his time. Stuart Williams thought it was his time a while back.
我告诉你，你跟大多数沙工谈谈，他们都会告诉你，当你的大限已到时，你的大限就到了。不管你是在街上走还是在地下工作，该走的总得走。你总会走的。当上帝说时间到了，你就走了。就是这样，简单明了。只是当时还不是他的时候。斯图尔特·威廉姆斯（Stuart Williams）不久前曾以为自己的大限已到了。
He was working on a subway job when suddenly the tunnel caved in. Stuart, whose only five foot three in ways less than 130 pounds, was nearly crushed to death. Damn, just feeling I ever had. I saw the most beautiful light on my way, my kids just just cleared the day and I passed out. I woke up in the hospital. I broke my leg, my back just threw the head cut open, broke the collarbone shoulder.
他在一个地铁工地工作，突然隧道坍塌了。斯图尔特身高只有五尺三寸，体重不到130磅，差一点被活活压死。该死的，那是我经历过的最奇妙的感觉。我在路上看到了最美丽的微光，我的孩子们刚刚在眼前清晰浮现，然后我就晕厥了。醒来时我已经在医院里了。我断了腿，背部受伤，头部被划破，锁骨和肩膀骨折。
But 8 weeks later, I remember it. 8 weeks. These days Stewart works above ground as a supervisor. Tonight he's directing a 650-pound dynamite blast at chaff 22, part of the water tunnel project in Brooklyn. Chaff 22 is wedged between the Brooklyn Queen's expressway and a row of low-income apartments that look down on the site. It's surrounded by loops of razor wire and bathed in high-intensity floodlights. Stuart blows a whistle once to warn people living in the apartment that an explosion is five minutes away. Dynamite blasts are in almost daily occurrence here. Still, Stuart is anxious. He's pacing back
但8周后，我记得清清楚楚。8周。如今，斯图尔特在地面上担任主管。今晚他在布鲁克林水隧道工程一部分的22号竖井指挥一场650磅的炸药爆破。22号竖井夹在布鲁克林-皇后区高速公路和俯瞰工地的低收入公寓楼之间。周围环绕着刺网圈，沐浴在高强度泛光灯下。斯图尔特吹了一声哨子，警告公寓里的居民五分钟后将发生爆炸。这里几乎每天都会发生炸药爆破。尽管如此，斯图尔特还是很焦虑。他来回踱步，
and forth, smoking a cigarette, nervously pushing the plunger on the empty detonator in and out, and greeting men as they come out of the shaft. How much possible for these men, man. Thank God, that's all I would. I've never hurt one in my life. I've had one get hurt working with me, and I don't want to start now. The one-minute warning, fire officials on hand to monitor the blast, move in closer and put their ear plugs in place. After 35 years of drilling and blasting, Stuart wears hearing aids in both ears. Well, when I started, they didn't have a ear protection they have now.
抽着烟，紧张地按压着空起爆器上的柱塞，并向走出竖井的工人们打招呼。这些人为这些人付出了多少啊，老兄。谢天我，我所能说的就是这些。我这辈子从未伤害过任何人。我从未让任何与我共事的人受伤，我也不想现在就开始。一分钟警告，现场监测爆破的消防官员走近并塞上耳塞。经过35年的钻孔和爆破，斯图尔特双耳都戴着助听器。嗯，我刚开始干的时候，他们可没有现在这种耳部防护。
They tried to tear a rag off for sure for sticking in your ear. The countdown is finally over. Stuart hands the detonator to the blast man who shouts out the final warning. Fire in the hole! Sound is good, sound is good. We'll know when we get down there. That's one of the things about shooting. You never know when you get back down there, what you got.
他们就试着撕下一块破布塞进耳朵里。倒计时终于结束了。斯图尔特将起爆器交给了爆破手，爆破手喊出了最后的警告：炮眼要爆破了！声音不错，声音不错。等我们下去就知道了。这就是爆破的特点之一。你永远不知道当你重新下去时，面对的会是什么。
I got to get the fan. He turns on the fan to clear the smoke out of the tunnel and heads for the Sandhog's locker room, the hog house, located in a nearby trailer for some barbecued ribs and a game of gin rumummy. I love it. I love it. Comerati with the man, the people, I've met some of the greatest people in the world. Worked with some of the greatest people in the world. And you get in and you get into your blood after a while. It's really all you want to do. There is a price Sandhog's pay for this love of the tunnels. You age, you age in the hole, so to speak. Many retired sandhogs, Huey Bar is one of them, suffer from silicosis, from years of breathing
我得把风扇拿来。他打开风扇吹散隧道里的烟雾，然后前往位于附近拖车里的沙工更衣室——“猪屋”（Hog House），去吃点烤排骨，玩一局金拉米纸牌。我爱这一行。我爱它。与这些人、这些人的同事情谊，我遇到过世界上最棒的一些人，与世界上最棒的一些人共事过。一旦你投入其中，它就会融入你的血液。这真的是你唯一想做的事。沙工们对隧道的热爱是有代价的。你会变老，可以说你在井里变老了。许多退休的沙工——休伊·巴尔就是其中之一——由于在隧道里长年呼吸
rock dust down in the tunnels, and caesons disease, a deterioration of the bone from working in compressed air. It puts a heart in on your body, so to speak. You can ask any of the old-timeers that joints hurt, you know, you're raking, you're raking. I don't think there's anyone who works as hard as a hog. Two men would load about a yard of sand in about two and a half to three minutes and this goes on continuously for six hours without a stop. I don't think there's
岩尘而患上了矽肺病，由于在高压环境下工作而患上了减压病（骨质退化）。可以说，这会损害你的身体。你可以问问任何老一辈的人，他们的关节都会痛，你知道的，你得铲土，你得铲土。我认为没有谁的工作能比沙工更辛苦。两个人要在大约两分半到三分钟内装载大约一立方码的沙子，而且这种工作连续进行六个小时一刻不停。我认为没有
only one that stands up with that kind of work. But I never regret it coming in and I'm never ashamed of being what I am. And this is what I am. When the ribbon cutting ceremony is finally held for City Tunnel No. 3, scheduled for completion in the year 2025, most of the sandhogs working on the project will have either retired or have died. 61-year-old Lincoln Richards may not be around, but he says there's satisfaction in just knowing he was part of it. Every time I go down and I come out after eight hours, I say, well, I've made my contribution. And to know what you're doing is that people would be able to enjoy it in the future.
其他人能承受这种工作。但我从未后悔入行，也从不为自己的身份感到羞耻。这就是我。当原定于2025年完工的3号市水隧道最终举行剪彩仪式时，大部分参与该项目的沙工要么已经退休，要么已经离世。61岁的林肯·理查兹可能已经不在了，但他表示，仅仅知道自己曾参与其中就心满意足了。每次我下去，工作八小时后上来，我都说，好吧，我做出了我的贡献。并且知道你在做的事情能让人们在未来享受到它。
Yes, this is something that after I die and go on, it would be still there. Because we're doing something that New York City would always have for the duration. Eddie McGinnis-Fat looks at another way. Eliminate all the tunnels the sand hogs have built over the years the Lincoln the Holland the Brooklyn battery the Long Island and Pennsylvania railroads the subways and you get an idea of the extent to which sand hogs help build New York well a picture a picture of New York City if you will what barges going across bring them people
是的，这就是自我死后多年仍会存在的东西。因为我们正在做的事情会让纽约市永远拥有它。埃迪·麦吉尼斯从另一个角度来看待这个问题。消除沙工多年来建造的所有隧道——林肯隧道、荷兰隧道、布鲁克林电池隧道、长岛和宾夕法尼亚铁路、地铁——你就会明白沙工对建设纽约的贡献有多大。好吧，如果你愿意想象一下纽约市的景象，运送人们过河的驳船，
across and ferries and the best ferry system in the world can carry about 80,000 people in a rush hour. That's like from 6 a.m. to 10 a.m. A tunnel can do that in 20 minutes. Without that progress of people coming back and forth, Manhattan would be a dead island. Manhattan would have been nothing. Why would you build anything for if you couldn't get people in and out? Three years and seven months it took to complete one tube of the Lincoln tunnel.
还有渡轮，世界上最好的渡轮系统在高峰期大约能运载8万人。也就是从早上6点到上午10点。而一条隧道在20分钟内就能做到这一点。如果没有这种人们来往的进步，曼哈顿将是一个死岛，曼哈顿将什么都不是。如果你不能让人流进进出出，你建任何东西又是为了什么？完成林肯隧道的一条管线花费了三年零七个月。
It opened to traffic December 22, 1937. Through the Lincoln tunnel, traffic moves with speed and safety 100 feet below the river. A new link joins the states of New Jersey and New York, a great engineering piece, a great highway, a new conquest of the Hudson. St. Hawks was produced by Dan Collison for Long Hall Productions. Long Hall Productions is Dan Collison and Elizabeth Meister. You can listen to all their stories and they got ton of great ones at longhallpro.org.
它于1937年12月22日对交通开放。通过林肯隧道，交通在河面下100英尺处安全迅捷地运行。一条新纽带连接了新泽西州和纽约州，这是一项伟大的工程，一条伟大的公路，哈德逊河的新征服。《沙工》由丹·科利森为长厅制作公司制作。长厅制作公司由丹·科利森和伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）组成。你可以在longhallpro.org上收听他们的所有故事，那里有大量精彩的内容。
99% Invisible is St. Green Sppan, Katie Mingle, Avery, Troubleman, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW, San Francisco, and produced of the offices of ArcSide, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter and Instagram too. And we have a new episode from Avery next week and you'll find it first at 99pi.org. Radio Topee from PRX. Tokyo.
99% Invisible 的成员有格林·斯潘（Sean Real/Green Span）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、埃弗里·特拉布曼（Avery Truffleman），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 电台的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心 ArcSide 建筑与室内设计事务所的办公室里。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目。我们在 Twitter 和 Instagram 上也都有账号。下周埃弗里将为我们带来一期新节目，你可以率先在 99pi.org 上收听。来自 PRX 的 Radio Topia。东京。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。